this one day he's bringing me to the
club
okay we're in the car
and he starts telling me larry
you know i love you like a son
okay you're very mature for your age and
i'm gonna have this conversation with
you because i know you can handle it i
know where he's going i know where he's
going and i feel the butterflies linda's
not in the car it's just you and him i
just meet him going to the club like
every day we get there at 12 30. the
rest of the guys come at one uh it's
just cause he would be there already
and sometimes one other guy was there
bobby but he wasn't there to stay so
we're driving there and i'm just being
quiet i'm actually like looking out the
window wondering what do i do now i said
this is it you know
you take me to the club and
i think i'm gonna get killed so
he's just talking about it doesn't say
he's going on how linda cares about you
and we're not that far from the club to
the house you know if there's no traffic
it's less than 10 minutes you know
uh so we get to the club now and we walk
in
just like this we're sitting like me and
you he goes behind the desk he's got his
big seat and i got a chair just like
this and i sit down and he's telling me
he says
i want you to know i know about you and
linda
so
i had a choice right there
okay i could have got up and run you
know which i didn't do
but i said to myself i've never forget
it's my moment of truth
this you know i still care for her i
don't want it to be over he
and i looked at him i said these are my
exact words okay it says greg
you're far from an idiot
and i have a lot of respect for you
you're far from an idiot only an idiot
won't see this he hit the test he starts
laughing he gets up i'm still a little
nervous we walk out together he puts his
arm around me okay we walk out in front
of the club it's just us too outside
this is a ritual for us he got himself
set up he put his paperwork away you
know
we go outside
and we're leaning on the parking meter
okay that's something we did you know
we've taken the sun
i was and he uh
goes on to tell me he's okay with this
because but the only thing is only the
three of us could ever know about it
he says if anybody else finds out you
and i will be killed
why you and i
well because he's breaking the rule too
he's breaking the rule by allowing it
okay uh and at that point i didn't i
mean i understand he's a made man he's a
mate you're not yeah okay no he's a made
guy all the way is he an earner or is he
a racketeer or is he more the the
bolted he's been described by that by
others including like sammy the bull
he's what he talked about our club he
says that 13th avenue club were
racketeers and killers and it's a lethal
it's about lethal obviously but it's a
it's a combination uh the consummate
that's the word i was looking for before
the ones that everybody looks up to and
fears and respects yeah you know and we
weren't the only ones i'm not saying
that
no i guess we were in that category
everybody in there if you're under greg
okay if he calls you with him you're
with me okay he introduces you to others
even it's a friend of mine at the
beginning you get the same respect as
anybody does and you're expected to
produce uh not only earn but carry
yourself like a good fella even if
you're not yet and
and and eventually you're going to be
hurting people and killing people just
the way it is if you're in that club
yeah in a circle it's going to happen
and it happened to me and we'll we'll
get there as we go
so now um ernie with him
i feel the weight of the world off my
shoulders
you know because we're able to go on and
we go on are three of you ever talking
about it openly when you're around each
other or no yeah so and let me ask you a
couple questions here so
uh uh one when i look at his background
he was married to connie and they
separated and he had been with libna for
30 years and connie had three kids
junior is one of them and with linda
they had two kids but i don't think they
ever officially got married with linda
right that's true okay so they were not
it was i didn't know that back then
later when i found out it was just
common law but
he never officially divorced connie
never did okay yeah all those nights he
was somewhere but there's a third wife
in there you knew that of course lily
yes okay the middle east and beauty yes
yeah yes so
a lot of time not a lot of times but
several times i took him to the airport
and she was in vegas
so he'd be gone for a day or two other
times he'd be picked up in a limo
uh and taken to manhattan and i wouldn't
see him for a day or two so he was
juggling to some point he spent every
full weekend in lakewood
you know with connie sure so you know
there's four or five nights a week i was
free to you know but there was also
later on nights where i said i knew he
came home and went in the basement
because i was there already
and we would we would actually meet
the coffee so if you like this sort of
short clip from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire interview
and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you